five four three two one
welcome everybody to another episode of
the genius parade podcast see I just
jump right into it I don't even [ __ ]
give anybody who heads up or a warning
by the way before we start this podcast
just to let you know and I've wrote this
written this in the comments stop
talking about my [ __ ] feet alright
number one I keep my feet on you without
socks because you tell me to put socks
on the more you tell me to do something
I'm not going to do it so [ __ ] all you
guys good morning everybody
that's right you guys keep your socks on
this and what I realized to what people
I actually cross my toes when I speak
and I didn't notice that [ __ ] your toes
it pretty animated yeah I'm always just
like are you really happy oh my god
what's going on I just like flooding
them around so today we have two very
special guests Jeremy and Anna as you
guys know I'm a part of a of a matcha
green tea spot called sip name change
pending soon but for now we're called
sip we've been doing this now for how
long it's been a while I think it's been
riding around a year and a half so I'm
somewhere around there longer in two
years
wait that's Morgan
July technically it depends where you
see the starting point well we started
as a pop up so if you're looking at that
then yeah so will you we simply such an
interesting concept and I think a lot of
people you know because you know me JK
we we kind of all started doing food at
different times right so I started off
with drips and swirls first and then
later on pop bar came along with you
guys and and everything else when you
guys started doing when you guys decided
to do sip what made you want to do
matcha in the first place so if you guys
don't know like obviously these concepts
that we invest into and they we work on
together is it wasn't really you didn't
really start with me in the JK crew we
came along afterwards so how did you
guys decide to start doing matcha I
think it was something that we just
wanted to bring to the states and bring
it in a different way I I don't know if
it's truly authentic I think it's
for us it's the way that I knew how to
enjoy mangia
yeah right and and if you go you went
there in the farmers that's the way they
enjoy it too yeah and so it's a little
different it's a cold brew way of doing
it it's a different method and for us it
was just we travel to Japan so often and
we laugh it's one of our favorite
destinations and one of the places that
we gather a lot of inspiration from and
so for us it was just all right how do
we then bring this experience back to LA
well I don't even know what [ __ ]
authenticity means anymore just because
like and I always tell people this when
it comes to food like people hold on to
this word authenticity so hard nowadays
right I don't know what it is it might
have to do with just lose that [ __ ]
word that I hate so much
oh appropriation right so it's like
people are taking this this food that
they loved growing up that maybe that
they thought that they used to get made
fun of for their whole life and somebody
else that's outside of that culture
makes a popular or some feeling that
right but authenticity is such a weird
thing for me with food because what
really is authentic right if you if you
really want to boil it down because
let's say for example let's say let's
say I was Chinese or Taiwanese right my
parents would make food different from
your parents rights correct yeah right
so whose food is authentic because if
you go to everybody's house everybody's
food tastes a little different right and
so people have different influences from
here and there and I think that's that's
the part that people get caught up in
because I always read that [ __ ] on Yelp
so when I when I go to a restaurant they
go
this [ __ ] is authentic and it's like
this [ __ ] taiwanese spot and this is
blue-eyed blonde-haired white girl it's
hype will do [ __ ] you dude and why does
it matter why does it matter to you so
much it's not even a part of your
[ __ ] culture in the first place right
yeah so I think like even for us like
when we do matcha I think that the the
great thing about thing that we do is
just there's this there's this concept
and I wrote about it on Instagram where
people have this idea that you have to
drink matcha in a very ceremonious way
right right and so there's even somebody
that I know that is trying to get
funding for this this docu-series that
they're doing worse war it's like about
like the whitewashing of like matcha and
stuff and you know to that person's
perspective they were trying to say like
it's a it's a serum it's a ceremonial
type of thing and I'm like [ __ ] have
you ever been to [ __ ] Japan
everybody be drinking matcha dude that
shit's right next to the condoms is such
a weird thing and I think like when we
started doing Sid the cool thing was
that our like our drinks are just just
fun yeah right yeah I mean there had to
be fun there had to be a little
different they had it we had to put our
own twist on it
and I think the reason being is it has
to be accessible in a way where people
can relate somehow yeah if they don't
know what it is then it's not gonna be
hard for them to try it if they know
what watermelon is and why don't we mix
the two yeah and then start there I
think our reasoning for me at a starship
was I wanted to make much of the right
way yeah because when we fell in love
with matcha from Japan we came back to
LA every single place that we had matcha
that was horrible like it just tasted so
diluted and it was brown it was murky it
wasn't what matcha was supposed to be
yeah so we're like why don't we bring it
back from Japan like source it from
Japan source from the farm that we know
and trust and bring it back to LA and
make it great yeah
and I don't want to hear anybody talk
about our matcha like it's not authentic
I [ __ ] saw like three
thousand-year-old Japanese women picking
that's right like I should you know
they're like yeah yeah it's amazing like
the work ethic and just just going there
you're so humbled because these are like
89 year old women and they are there's
one at it yeah they're harvesting the
matcha and they're doing their thing
they're so lively - yeah I'm kind of
shot I think like the whole hand picking
process threw me off because when we
were traveling to other matcha tea farms
that weren't ours I saw the whole
machine process that were they where
they literally slice off the top of
whatever the young blood of the bush and
they just machine process usually by
[ __ ] head yeah it was amazing right
yeah that's why why sometimes when I
read these things are like oh this is an
authentic awesome I don't know what more
I don't know what this authentic word is
but I don't know what more you want from
us you should talk to these old ladies
they're literally picking it by [ __ ]
hand yeah I mean that's for quality
control and and these ladies they do
like 20 kilos a day easy that's crazy
that's a lot the only four foot ten yeah
there's that the shade because the green
tea leaves are shaded there's no way I
could do that because I'm bet half way
over but they're just standing up
straight so it has to be 90 year old
people it's pretty crazy when you guys
when we started you guys did what before
we would you guys were doing um shrimp
daddy came before shrimp daddy was first
yeah
shrimp daddy and all of our concepts we
started with Jun and Dan I don't think
it would have been possible food is so
so difficult yeah that that we were we
knew that too and I think a part of us
were like man we got it we gotta find
partners and do it with somebody because
food is just it's taxing number one yeah
it's it's hard to so it's really fun to
start something the real challenge is to
maintain and sustain it yeah yeah right
right so and and relationship yeah kind
of I guess you could explain it that way
mmm and so shrimp daddy was number one
shrimp daddy is coming up on three years
and of this year and in November and
then after that was the shave ice
concept chichi dango that's right yeah
Hawaiian shave ice and then after that
was yeah so you know what the
interesting thing is like I remember
when you guys first approached us about
sit outside hell this is gonna be dope
right it's funny because like when when
sometimes like we I think it's investors
where we're still individuals right so
there's you know Bart and geo is there
danger is his thing
I'm my own thing and then everybody kind
of pulls together to see what we want to
invest in and what we really want to
push depending on the story of the
product and if we really can back it for
me like SIPP was my was my favorite
concept out of everybody out of all the
stuff right because then what shrimp
daddy a ship daddy's grade and also
chichi Tonga which I very much love but
for some reason like sip to me just
always it always just stuck out I
remember like when we first started I
think like people were a little
apprehensive with with sip just because
like we have already they have already
invested into two major projects I think
like sip for them was something that was
a little a little rocky for them because
they were like oh well we already have
two should we invest into a third one
and I think like sip was such a great
move for us because like number
a lot of people don't know about it
right and I think that education process
isn't gonna be the the hard part even
when we put a post and like I wrote
something very simple where I said
you're machi shouldn't be bitter and
they're like what what what do you mean
it's not supposed to be they're supposed
to be bitter and like it's not supposed
to be bitter and that's actually one of
the reasons why people don't like it
because whatever they had was very
accurate it's very acrid bitter and they
don't like that that feeling that leaves
in your mouth right and I think that was
is the biggest challenge to make much of
really accessible to people because
there's this whole thing about number
one they don't know what it is right
number two they don't know what it does
for you right and number three they
don't even know what they should taste
for right so this is this is like the
the uphill battle that we have to face
with this and I think that for us the
best way to do it was to make it fun
right
so I think because we do a lot of fruit
drinks we do a lot of mixed drinks and
we do a lot of drinks that just you
probably typically want to see done with
matcha right yeah that's correct
I think the fruit drinks were a after so
after doing this I think the food drinks
came from actually getting feedback from
the audience yeah they were they wanted
the fruit drinks they wanted the the
watermelon they wanted the the mango and
the strawberry and it was only after we
were like okay well because we came from
this purity mindset let's bring it in a
way where people can really enjoy in its
purest form let's keep the tradition
let's keep the tradition and then for
your for the most part were like alright
let's let's hold off on these there's
the reason why we didn't launch
strawberry right when we launched it
yeah and and so after a while we're like
alright let's accept the fact that
people actually want this and let's give
it to them I think for us it took some
time to evolve to when we launched it
because originally the idea was a little
different than where it is today yeah
it's just about adapting to to the
feedback that we're getting and and I
think a part of that is people like when
it's fun people like when it's fruit
forward people like that and a part of I
think because we grew up on tea too so a
part of
what we were trying to accomplish and
what actually people wanted or a little
different yeah so that tea culture I
don't know if you can say it's tea
culture because most of the people in LA
I grew up on tea here they are used to
something more bitter yeah I think it's
like the Listerine effect where if it's
not burning it's not working oh yeah
it's not good yeah and I think they we
all grew up on that thinking this is
what good to you the better the better
yeah and it was until traveling more it
wasn't until learning more about tea at
at the level that we do it that we found
that Oh actually good tea is really
subtle yeah it's sweet it has a natural
sweetness to it it's there's a lot of
umami - it feels creamy on the palate
yeah and we really try to just bring
that back showcase it
it wasn't received as well as we would
think hello everybody this podcast is
brought to you by purple now if you
haven't had a purple mattress bless the
back side or the side of your body I'm
telling you right now you're missing out
I'm guaranteeing that you're probably
like me before I had a purple mattress
waking up in the middle of night maybe
you're too hot maybe you're too cold
well guess what just like those bears
and that porridge this mattress is just
right my friends is sebat hrus that's
like soft and firm at the same time and
ever since I had this mattress has
changed my life I love this mattress I
love it if you're a big dude small dude
whatever this mattress is for you the
technology in it is amazing and I'm
telling you right now I have never slept
any better in my life
I love it well guess what people you're
going to love purple and right now my
listeners will get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress that's
in addition to the great free gifts
they're offering site-wide just text
brain to eight four - eight eight eight
the only way to get this free pillow
it's the text brain - eight four - eight
eight eight
that's B R a I n - eight four eight
eight eight
yeah yeah I think it was a little too
early for its time and also a little too
how would I say a little too bougie if
you will
yeah for most people to enjoy yeah then
so we had to bring in the fruit stuff
because that's what people were
requesting and this is whole educational
process which you helped a lot with I
think your posts did a lot for us it was
just kind of like shocking I was like oh
[ __ ] maybe and I think like what's I
think because when you become so
enveloped into learning about something
you forget how not commonplace certain
things that we know are to other people
right right like how it should taste you
know the the the effects that that
matcha have has on you right right even
for I mean why is I always think about
like why coffee is so popular right yeah
and even people who have opinions about
coffee there's this people a lot of
people don't know about coffee right but
they always have an opinion on it which
is so fascinating to me right yes I I
don't know [ __ ] about coffee like we've
taken coffee classes there was like a
point where I just started looking over
try to copy other people's notes you're
not paying attention
I was not angularfire coffees hard for
me just like just like drinks or like
for example on ascend foods we went to
we went we always go wine or beer
tasting right I think beer is a lot
easier for me to taste the difference
because there's a stark difference in
between each flavors right so if they
say like this was aged and a bourbon
barrel I'll take I'll taste bourbon
right off the bat right right if they
say there were there was cranberries and
cherries steeping to this alright I'll
taste it right off the bat but with wine
wine is something that I [ __ ] I
[ __ ] hate because I have to sit there
and then pretend like I don't know about
you because like these salmon days will
come up it's like well this is so if you
have this Chardonnay right here you can
taste like the the oaky the oaky [ __ ]
fruity notes off in the summer breeze
this meat is not and I go yes I do
yeah my mind I'm like no I don't know
why is really tough right what I don't
understand how some people could do a
blindfold test and this crazy girl have
you seen that documentary on Netflix
called Somme yeah I number one I have
never met people that I was thoroughly
impressed with and number two people I
always wanted to beat up at the same
time like I wanted to tell everybody
shut the [ __ ] up in that thing
the way they described wine to crack me
up so they like it was this one
descriptor he is he goes tastes like a
hot summer's day and a freshly cut
garden hose or you sniff the inside what
the [ __ ] did you just say and why the
[ __ ] would I want to drink that but then
they would they they they smell they
tasted they see whatever the [ __ ]
viscosity or whatever and they go in
Italy in the summer of 1962 passive it
was a drought that year because the the
grapes were nice sweet and there wasn't
as much water or there was there wasn't
as much water so the the sweet is more
concentrated made by old lady stuff in a
vagina got a right just move on from it
I think like with matcha - eventually
I'm not sure if he'll get to that extent
but when people take an interest in it
they'll they'll be able to see the
difference right and not just say it you
know cuz they're I think now because
like we drank it so much I mean
obviously if it's like you know Sariel
ceremonial matcha to another ceremonial
matcha I mean that requires probably a
definitely a more sophisticated palate
right but just from bad good medium
great you should you could see and taste
the difference well the the great thing
about matcha is there's really only one
origin now Japan yeah why not other hand
it's worldwide right and then and then
coffee - it's there's a lot of different
origins hmm and it had a long time to
evolve wine and coffee and so coffees
what on third phase t really is it
hasn't really evolved at all mmm and so
most people that have the knowledge or
like our parents and their generation
and we're barely scratching the surface
so for us to then go and educate on this
is even tougher we do have one thing
work in our favor which is single origin
yeah and and that kind of gets all the
confusion out because if it's coming
from somewhere else other than Japan
then you probably shouldn't drink it mmm
and then if if it was coming from Japan
it's usually pretty good it's just you
have to discern whether it's good bad
better or excellent yeah because there's
also this concept where people though I
think it's funny because I some people
will you know I go to a lot of the
marketplaces to depending cuz if I'm not
in the area of ours and I'll go
somewhere else but then you know I look
up reviews and I I always love reading
reviews about much of places just
because of like the [ __ ] that people say
right they go I've been to Japan
this isn't matcha and I'm like well you
mean in Japan there's a lot of shitty
matcha all right like so what it what
does that mean like I don't know what
that [ __ ] means right and we're in
this like this weird culture of
everybody wants to be an expert about
something and I feel like when you're
when you even faked to be an expert you
get like some type of clout from it
right so like my favorite type of Yelp
reviews are the person that starts off
with so I woke up this morning the Sun
was bright today was gonna be a good day
I fed my dog I petted my dog fluffy was
really cute so because I saw fluffy I
thought maybe fluffy pancakes like [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] died on tree about your
life [ __ ] tell me about the breakfast
joint you [ __ ] hoe like it irritates
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out the thing is there
a curse to write more like when you
write a yelp review it's like keep going
keep going you're almost beyond your
paragraph and then when you write enough
then nothing oh this is always good okay
it tells you my god that's infringing
you as you go cuz I just want to see the
[ __ ] nitty gritty right I want to see
what you you could dislike something
that's fine I just want to know what you
disliked about it right what you liked
about it yeah and those are my favorite
because I could just see it so when I
used to like write Yelp reviews I just
did I did pros cons ambiance and I just
wrote it bop bop-bop-bop I like doing
bullet points yeah I would always do
because that's what I want to see right
now saying what do I like about this
place these are my favorite dishes what
do I dislike this right here overall
score I [ __ ] with this place move on and
I would I would do a certain because you
can't respond to people on Yelp I would
write a review trashing the person
beneath me but just because they would
have left it was a lot of people and I
think if Yelp did that it would be great
because if it has an open community you
have to be responsible for the things
that you say correctly because that's
that's the hard part because as a
business owner you can either directly
them or you have to put a public
statement for everybody else to see it's
tricky for a business owner you almost
don't want to publicly
yeah that's such them and then talk
about it yeah other than hey I sent you
a DM yeah because it's kind of in the
open domain and if you're gonna really
hash something out I think it's better
to keep it private
yeah and so it's really tricky for his
dough just don't want people that leave
away upset I think yes the more
upsetting part for me when somebody
walks out of our store upset
like I'm not mad that you left a bad
review I just want to know why you're so
angry or what did we do to [ __ ] up or
maybe give us a chance to make right
yeah or somewhere you leave right cuz
it's not it's not so much I think when
when I talk about this stuff people go
well you know are you so mad I'm not mad
at them not really it's just more like
[ __ ] I wish I had the opportunity to
make this right
yeah I wish you would have given me the
chance to at least for you to walk away
feeling okay or at best walk away with a
smile even if you don't like our stuff
because I just don't like it when people
just thank you for giving us a chance of
coming into the store but if you're
gonna talk that [ __ ] say in front of our
face will be it apologize you not even
give me the opportunity apologize like
[ __ ] man like give me give me something
yeah we have a sign of the store that
says if you're not happy with your drink
let us know we can make it right
but I think a lot of people just get
their drink they take a sip they're not
happy they just leave yeah but we tell
our team to encourage them to tell the
customers please give us another chance
like if you're not happy with your drink
taste it let us know how you like it let
us do it right so you can leave happy
yeah and if you don't like it that's
that's completely fine just you know at
least give a business owner a chance and
I'm pretty sure even you know just maybe
just to defend them a little bit they
probably have situations where they
spoke up to an owner and they got
trashed on foot I've seen it oh yeah
I've seen in person yeah it's just
amazing how people respond like oh yeah
it's well why did you order that drink
that I think you don't like it what what
you ordered it I don't understand how
some business owners can train their
employees to do that it's it's weird man
like I think like having a business is
so
difficult there's so many moving parts
and I think a lot of people who listen
to this they want to know well how do we
get to that point like how do we because
it's it's always easier said than done
like I know somebody right now who mind
you he makes great food right great food
or amazing food is literally I into me
in my personal opinion like 35 percent
of the game when it comes to opening up
a restaurant right and in his mind so he
just recently split with his other
partners at his restaurant right and
they had a very successful restaurant
and still up and running now but they
split and and you know from his point of
view and his story what I heard was that
they didn't know what they were doing
when it came to the business side of
things and he knows better I was like
cool I trust his judgment I mean they
have a very successful restaurant
turns out he goes off somewhere else and
he opens up a very similar concept and I
went to the restaurant and food is
similar but everything else is trash
right and so the mistake that he made
was that he actually underappreciated
what his partners did right so in his
mind he thought that he knew better he
goes I know how to make the food and the
reason why people are coming through
these doors is because the food is so
great
well that is partly true but what
happens is is if you don't have the
customer service correct you're not
training your staff correctly you're not
training the kitchen right you like
you're not you don't have the system set
in place everything starts to fall apart
and their food gets affected by that too
and that's what he's experiencing right
now it goes I don't get it like I pay my
people well like this is the same thing
that we did over there I don't
understand why it's not working well
it's not working because you don't
understand what it took to run the place
because you were mr. chef mr. cook guy
right you made the food but you didn't
see all the moving parts and so what's
happening with I mean the place is still
doing fine but it's just not as great as
he thought it would be and I think what
he realized was like oh [ __ ] I actually
don't know what I'm doing you know yeah
so so when you guys started doing sip I
mean I I think number one what I like
about our company the most was is
company culture and I think that's
really important to you guys right
definitely that's true and I handles
most of that I'm in charge of HR so
dude managing people is an art so what
is what is something that you do to keep
like like our company culture just
flowing and going right
I think it's many different aspects of
it the first part is intuition when it
comes to hiring people because I have a
pretty good sense of someone right when
I meet them like within like 10 minutes
of talking to them I can know whether or
not they'll be a good fit for the
company and so first you have to select
the right group of people to come and
join the team and the second is you have
to know how to cultivate them yeah
because we do we're not paying them like
you know great salary or anything it's
like they're doing they're doing so much
for what they're getting paid for but
what we give them I feel like speaks
volume yeah like what we put into them
and what the time and effort that we
invest into them I think it's what makes
it worth it yeah and that's why we do
team activities like we take them to the
Hollywood Bowl we take them to concerts
you take them to movies we take them to
rock climbing just any activities we
could think of that will help us become
stronger as a team yeah and then we
really really care about them as people
I mean we we do evaluations pretty often
what we call we're not calling them
evaluate since anymore yeah and the
traditional sense they would be
considerate evaluations it's actually
just we set aside time to talk with them
yeah to catch up without distractions
right so we get to meet up talk about
things see how they're doing see how
their experiences on the job see how we
can improve another yeah there are any
opinions for that and I think they're
looking for community I think they're
looking for for for lying a sense of
belonging and sense a voice to be heard
the the pay isn't as significant as most
people think it is yeah because number
one its food so it's gonna be either one
of your first five jobs right and you're
not expecting to live off of the salary
you're not expecting a $60,000 salary
from working at a restaurant yeah and so
for most of them they're looking for
community and if other restaurant owners
can provide that that means a lot to
them yeah when I feel cared for yeah
that too yeah like that when I feel
we really care about their well-being
which we do yeah and we show that by
being there for them through all the ups
and downs I have my team that come to me
often and say this is happening in my
personal life this is happening at my
family this is happening my
relationships what can I do so I'm
pretty much their therapist that's so
nice but I love doing that because I see
how they grow I see how they evolve into
the person that they are today it's
because we've been pushing them every
step of the way we've been there for
them we've been there
we pretty much you have been there
second parents yeah I mean that's what
some of them tell us coz that's crazy
cuz you know for me I mean I'm you know
when you guys work whatever part-time
jobs before I look I never got that I
never got that you know we would come in
we clock in we clock out and if there
was a girl that I like that I [ __ ]
flirt with her and maybe get fired later
on you know I mean like there's you know
that type of [ __ ] right there wasn't
this this this feeling where I felt
except for one guy and he's actually I
used to work at the the Men's Wearhouse
and he was my manager we still talk and
hang out till this day and I think like
those type of like relationships are so
hard to find especially at a part-time
job because these jobs are supposed to
be very fleeting right like you come in
you get your paycheck you move I think
the great thing is that you guys
actually take the time to develop these
people as human beings because one of
the things that I found very difficult
specifically when people when I used to
have a bigger team people would kind of
my thing is it like this if you even if
it's a part-time job you work that
part-time job like is a full-time job
yeah you're right sorry we like I would
always expect people to put their best
foot forward no matter what it doesn't
matter like because it's it's a
precursor and an example of what you're
going to do later on in your future job
yes because there's no such thing as
I'll do this part time job half-assed
and I'm a kick-ass at my other job yeah
you don't cuz by the time you're done
with that part-time job you've already
built those bad habits yeah and they
stick with you yeah that's what people
don't understand in that hiring process
too like I think some of my friends when
they hire some of their employees were
their businesses they don't understand
like well how did this person who I
thought seemingly was supposed to be
great turns out to be so bad I was like
no well there was a lot of bad habits
that they had you just said it was a
part-time job and you let it go but
those bad habits develop into permanent
habits easy yeah
because it's repetitious anything that
you do whether you're developing a great
quality or a bad quality repetitions
make sure that it stays in place yeah
right so when somebody doesn't do
something and you let it slide they'll
do it again and again and again right to
me to like you have any idea how many
times so you know what you would slash
mountain right everybody has their hands
we see this picture I see I feel hands
about my throat but I was trying to hold
on to something and you held on to my
next second my god that's where she felt
safe so for example like when Muriel I
moved in together right she so after the
splash so the reason why Muriel decided
to go on Splash Mountain was because I
promised that every time I use my
bathroom which I call it my safe space
my mancave that I would leave the toilet
seat down and the top lid down so
because that's not an ingrained habit
but she hasn't seen it though right so
she hasn't but I just use your bathroom
and you put the seat down yeah but she's
not here to witness it so that's just
your story all right I could is your
story versus minor I just know that
whenever I hear her that she's coming
into the door I just run into my
bathroom you just put the toilet seat
down camera in the back well I mean it's
very normal though because I think it
takes time to build a habit oh well
they're good or bad 121 days 21 days at
minimum for it to start taking and then
90 days for it to stick so she if you're
doing anything for three months straight
it's gonna start sticking yeah and it
might be permanent or it might take just
as long to undo or even longer you just
do it for three months yeah you just
have to do it for three months like I
just think it's so dumb is so much extra
work it's my bathroom let me pee and poo
wherever I want
dammit and then when people come in
it'll be clean all right don't don't
worry about it but for her she's just
like she looks at like the microscopic
details right she's just like this is
dirty look at that what have you done
like even this place right now it's
pretty clean it's clean it's really cut
it's not clean to her why this is not
clean to her you see that tray with
that yes she told us about that trailer
yeah that's right that's where you put
everything yeah that's my chaos tray
right so I I will have certain amount of
clutter but I will have it in a
designated area and that's what that
damn tray is for so for that she hates
that there's like a couple boxes right
there
that's unacceptable to her so yeah I
think it looks clean to me it's pretty
clean that's but that's what I'm saying
though right so what I always tell her
is that you have no idea how clean I am
as a person I was like you are the
unreasonable one because everybody who
walks into this place they go this place
is pretty clean right but to her she
just goes I don't get it I should do
this the countertop and then like it oh
she's just that though the white glove
yeah she sees all because you
masturbated a lot today didn't you
I can see all the stains everywhere [ __ ]
so when you guys Oh what I didn't know
actually I found out about this dude Joe
a while back so you guys actually have
another functioning business outside of
a sip
chichi dango and shrimp daddy that's
correct right huh
what is it those the first business we
started together yeah it's a it's a
photobooth business in New York City and
it's still running today and I think
that's where we learned a lot of
fundamentals because it's still running
we we had to make a decision one day and
we're like okay if we move back to LA
what do we do with the business everyone
was like you can't run the business from
across the country yeah you can't you
just simply can't it's not gonna survive
and that was 2013 oh [ __ ] well how are
you guys running the business right our
computer Oh computer anything remotely
and so so most people while most people
see a laptop for browsing the Internet
yeah and a cell phone for for surfing
Instagram it actually can change your
life right this little device can change
your life and so that's what we learn
and I think it was it's it's a couple
things I think we're lucky enough to
have the tech to support it yeah if this
was 20 years ago no way our parents
could have done this
yeah there's no way you could run a
remote business 20
go yeah but now you have the technology
to do it
you just need then I guess the
infrastructure or the the home the team
the human resources to support that yeah
because we don't meet these team members
every day and talk to them on a regular
basis yeah or at least face-to-face
everything is done through text phone
call an email or a quick phone call and
so it's even harder to create that
culture when there's no face-to-face hmm
really it's a lot harder yeah and I
think it's I mean if we're being honest
it's a little less enjoyable to on our
side because you love to face-to-face
and ask there's less of a connection and
but we try to make it work and I think
because we try to make it work and it's
been working for six years is how we
learn how to create a better dynamic in
person yeah so when you so are you guys
like I mean what's the word I'm looking
for
if you weren't doing all of our food
businesses right with all of us together
yeah that's like kind of like that's
like semi-retirement right like if you
just kind of like remotely do things it
offers a lot of flexibility yeah yeah so
you could travel on travel you could I
mean you could if you could do it across
the country then you could do it
anywhere in the world
yeah it just gets a little more
inconvenient with the time zone
situation yeah we've lived in China too
so we were able to make it work
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy dude yeah
that's [ __ ] insane you stupid son of
a [ __ ] look at that cuz I think
that's the hard part it's like I'm so
used to so many hands-on things right so
when I saw my parent's donut business
they were hands-on about everything
right and I think when people you kind
of get stuck in that that type of system
right where do you feel like you can't
let go a certain way you can't allow
people to do stuff that you feel like
it's something that only you can do you
feel like you have to be in control
mm-hmm the business yeah I think control
I think it comes from a place of
insecurity mm what if they don't do it
as well as I can
yeah and therefore you time travel in
two years the business might not
do well in three years if we might go
belly-up yeah so you you kind of project
these things onto the business that
don't even exist yet instead of dealing
with it now you know like let's figure
out right now how can we can move back
to LA and make this work like let's not
think about what happens a year from now
if people start leaving let's not let's
not get to that point let's think about
how we fix it now there was a thing
learning experience of because when we
first started the business in 2010 we
were so hands-on yep
we went to so we started the photobooth
company in 2010 yeah 2010 yeah and we
wanted to be the one to be at every
single event with our photo booth to
provide the best customer service from
an experience to make sure every single
print is printing out beautifully to
make sure props are being organized to
make sure the clients happy we wanted to
do it all so he was working full-time at
engineering firm and doing this and
nights and weekends before he probably
had like 4 hours of sleep every night
for like oh well yeah
or else was a good night sorry I had to
biohacking like allow my body to like
reach REM quickly what's here what's
your optimal amount of sleeping time for
you no I think naturally you have an 8
actually 8 hours and that's good I'll
just wake up 4 hours 4 hours for me
really yeah so any more than that you
you feel like sluggish or you feel like
you're like I I sleep average 4 hours ok
yeah that's why you take naps I'm
actually 18 years old 4 hours a really
good sleep that's technically all you
really need
it's it's hard for me that's like I've
always like struggled with sleep I mean
when I get eight hours though I feel
like I'm on steroids like I feel [ __ ]
fan-fucking-tastic like the other night
I slept like six or seven I started
boxing in the gym before the Muay Thai
class and I felt [ __ ] fantastic but
first but because I slept so well that
day last night
I was too energetic I couldn't I
couldn't go to sleep so I slept like
four hours and it [ __ ] sucks Wow
I worked out twice like I don't it's
[ __ ] sex I need like seven hours at
least that's why you [ __ ] like a
child beauty sleep you look like you rub
your face and placenta do you look so
[ __ ] young baby everybody looks so
[ __ ] young to me I'm like you guys
age so [ __ ] well do well you don't
look that old either that's all because
the clothes I'm wearing but that's also
because I think I'll well I [ __ ] had
better eating habits and everything else
to drinking water [ __ ] man [ __ ]
drinking water that helps out a lot it
does I don't know clue our Asian parents
have been telling us that our whole
lives
my mom doesn't drink water at all miss
[ __ ] she refuses to drink water like
when we go out to eat I have to sit
there and the force of the drink water
she's such a [ __ ] child this woman's
like 70 years old she gets a cup right
she goes look I drink water - oh let's
like drink your [ __ ] water
like my dad he doesn't drink anything
besides juice or coffee or tea that's my
mom - she's just coffee she goes coffees
water I was like no it's not as happy
and it dehydrates you woman she said
that doesn't happen dude that doesn't
really exist
she refuses to drink water I don't I
don't [ __ ] understand till this day
she just people can do it without ya I
drink warm water I love warm water water
it's good for your body you know if you
guys ever follow her dude just know that
you'll see some hokey-pokey Asian
remedies that's she seriously it could
be 90 degrees outside she's gonna get
yep you like hot [ __ ] well I thought
that's dead hot water dude that's her
jam like he loves it if it's tea if it's
coffee I get it
hot chocolate lovely when you wake up in
the morning drink a warm cup of water I
should better give you a cynic give me a
six-pack and a larger penis I don't want
to do it what the [ __ ] how long have you
been doing that for oh man maybe like
it's ten years you ever noticed the
bottle her water bottle is actually like
a thermos like those Japanese thermos
bottle well I thought that was because
you're trying to keep it cold so such
good warrants
my god you know what blue or water is
the perfect temperature for bacteria you
are a living bacteria [ __ ] dare you
how can bacteria survive in hot water is
it hot water as a lukewarm water it's
pretty hot what no [ __ ] how do you drink
that [ __ ] you know what that's true
though now that I think about it that is
true dead bacteria in my water should I
be drinking Cola it should be above 130
degrees you're [ __ ] crazy why would
you drink hot water so you must water
and I'm trying to warm it up in my mouth
yeah it's gotta get the body temp before
we get to the stomach I will boil that
[ __ ] to an oblivion next time for you
did that should sue me steam coming
right when you got the cold water you're
just like oh god this guy [ __ ] cold
water bastard trying to kill me what
else do you do that's so [ __ ] weird
hot showers well I take hot showers all
the time I like really really hot shot I
think a sauna I think a lot of these
things that you do they all came about
when we start trying for babies are
trying hmm yeah there's a lot of weird
stuff we started oh yeah we started
trying you know that whole process
especially for you guys like the it's so
interesting because like I've never seen
somebody try so hard to have a kid right
and I feel like for you guys there are
other options but having your own child
just from that means is so important to
you and what why is that I think for me
it's like you ever feel like you're in
this world for a reason like there's
your purpose your calling I feel like my
purpose has always been to be a mom mmm
so growing up I knew I wanted to be a
mom and you I wanted to have two to
three kids I wanted to raise good human
beings I would do good in this world
yeah I don't know why I just it was like
my calling and so I first started trying
I was like it has to happen being the
control freak that I am I was like it
has to happen immediately it has to
happen on this timeline in this year
they had to be born of this month so
they'll have this horoscope sign I goes
trying to control it all so when it
wasn't happening over and over again it
was like definitely a humbling
experience I have to why I think it
starts the control factors starting
before because you're also thinking
we're not ready yet we have to get to a
certain point in our lives where we feel
like we're ready everything is set up
and it was with the other business where
we felt like okay everything is remote
now yeah we can spend time with the kids
the imaginary kids that we were trying
to project him yeah and plan for and
then it's like okay now we're ready why
is it happening yeah yeah like we did
everything by the book we wanted to have
a stable job we wanted to have enough
income to have security and have a house
have the relationship the marriage that
we have and the support system that we
have and everything was ready and then
we're like okay where's the baby
when is the baby coming yeah so what
what is the what's the IVF process like
because that's what you guys are doing
right yes IVF is in simple terms having
a baby through science okay so it's
called in vitro fertilization it's a
process of injecting myself with a lot
of shots to give me hormones to grow my
eggs farming farming in my uterus
farming farming and farming her eggs
every month you have you release an egg
but when you do shots you farm like 10
20 30 eggs so the ovaries usually this
big mm-hmm they become one shake she's
farming they grow to the size of a
grapefruit
what the [ __ ] yeah cuz one egg could fit
in this right like a ping-pong yeah
imagine then you have 15 eggs because
you have two ovaries 15 eggs on each
side and so each ovary she was wearing
my pants at one point yeah I couldn't
fit into my own clothes I look like I
was pregnant but I wasn't yeah that's
how big her ovaries like god only
[ __ ] baby go under anesthesia and
then they surgically remove the eggs and
then they put it in into a petri dish
with his sperm and they try to grow and
them into embryos and then when they
grow into embryos you have to wait for
day three
day five and see their viable embryos
and you transfer it back into me in
hopes of implanting and then you grow a
human being yeah Jesus that's [ __ ]
crazy
in my mind I didn't know that it
expanded or anything like that I just
thought it was like a little egg like a
little little salmon roe it is it is cuz
I think at maturity it's like 20
centimeters mm-hmm I mean I'm about 20
millimeters yeah 20 centimeters like
that one 20 millimeters and so yeah
maturity there they're like little
salmon eggs so imagine you have 30 of
them mm-hmm holy [ __ ] right that it gets
pretty big that that surgical process is
that very painful you don't really feel
anything you just go under but we had a
really bad experience the first time I
almost died really I almost died but no
but what happened was she you could tell
the story cuz I wasn't in the room with
her I think I owe you son of a [ __ ] oh
yeah waiting room outside I think I
would have overreacted for sure though
so they put me under well before they
put me under the doctor was like how is
your alcohol tolerance and I was like I
think it's pretty good because I think
I'm like my dad like I could drink a lot
without getting drunk cuz I was like I
think it's pretty good and so she gave
me I was like but I haven't drink in a
while so I'm not sure and then she gave
me a huge dose of what do you call it
proper something it's some kind of some
drug some drug to make me go under but
it was so strong that my heart stopped
beating and so you hear yourself
flatline and then I see I hear the
doctor shaking me and saying breathe
breathe breathe breathe wake up wake up
breathe breathe and I was like like my
life just flashed before my eyes and I
was like [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] die yeah
and then she was like shaking me shaking
me and I was like trying so hard to
force myself to breathe and then I
suddenly started breathing again and I
could hear my heartbeat again and then
after that she's like okay I'm not going
to
any more drugs we're just gonna start
the retrieval process and I was awake
the entire time so I like I felt like
pressure I felt like we were that
uncomfortable and then that retrieval
was actually very difficult because they
didn't retrieve any eggs successfully so
I was a bust so I went through all that
just again nothing at the end and then
when I came out to the waiting room and
the doctor told me that I she didn't get
anything and that it was a failed
retrieval I just burst into tears no it
was like why does this keep happening to
us and I told him about what happened
and he was furious and he's like
thinking about suing her he's thinking
about taking action he's thinking about
so many things that could have gone
wrong and he that was I mean we were
like maybe we should take a break yeah
he told me he's like I don't want to
lose you in this process of trying to
have a baby yeah so that kind of hit me
and I was like that's true like I don't
want our marriage to be you know the end
the place where he was and going through
all this and then risking my life to try
to have this baby yeah it's the weirdest
thing because you're it's like this
thing that you're trying to work towards
but the same time you don't want to work
towards yeah cuz the resemble it's the
ultimate price to pay like it is it
worth it mmm is it worth it and and I
think at the time I was so furious but
at the same time it was like she wasn't
ready to fight yeah cuz like she was
devastated after that yeah
and I was like wow but I want to I want
to do something about the situation but
she was like she just feels so shitty
and and she wants to like just isolate
herself in like she's just is this weird
balance it wasn't like we were in sync
at that time because she just gone
through what she's been through and it's
not only that it's like the hormones too
that you have to inject yourself with
they make you crazy crazy oh really
crazy yes imagine PMS every month I
don't know Muriel has PMS and she's oh
she does does imagine what she goes
through every month at the worst time in
like ten times that not just it's not
that straightforward - it's like alright
so like when we were in
China I remember this vividly because
you know at that time a month yeah she's
she's counting the days she's timing the
window yeah it becomes very romant and
it's time right and alright one thing
about that I think nobody wants to get
here in their marriage where it's like
oh it feels like routine now if you yeah
that's planned it feels like oh right
now it's optimal so now we got to do it
doesn't matter what we're doing we got
to do this yeah and so in China there's
this one moment where she was taking
some medication for it and it's the
weirdest thing because she's like she's
like in the mood mmm but she's also in
the mood to kill me you know so she's
like me now before I kill you
yeah okay it's time and then oh and at
this time we were ladies lion king [ __ ]
he's died yeah and then we we were at
her parents place so she's like yeah get
quiet though and so her parents like
right next door the other row nice and
then so you know we're cool like we're
trying and we're trying and it's like
she crosses over from in the mood to I
want to kill you I was like I can't go
any faster like I have to be quiet I you
know I'm conscious of friction yeah and
then on top of that it's like it's not
our bed because I'm not used to knowing
where it squeaks and where it does oh
yeah yeah like conscious about that too
and then she's like oh yeah that's gonna
make him calm oh god Anna look a [ __ ]
because not only not it was late so he
had stuff planned the next day and it
was like oh I can't just hurry up
yeah and like the deaths there yeah
hoping either he's going limp he's like
yeah don't you [ __ ] dare get
something better keep that [ __ ]
rock-hard yeah yeah yeah so that was
like one of my memories like first
memories of us trying and trying to do
it abroad and in China because we we saw
the doctor here but we brought the
medicine with us and yeah it's just you
know you threaten him and [ __ ] him at
the same time expected this relationship
you're like enjoying it all son you just
like okay I'm like we're not gonna make
a baby you don't come well that's it
have to make it happen it wasn't like
it's hard to [ __ ] somebody who's angry I
just like staring at them with [ __ ]
anger and [ __ ] did I get blinking hi
[ __ ] blink and wasn't like it was a now
or later usually come in a minute all
you had to do was just [ __ ] do my
hands it but right before you stick it
right in real better yeah it's so much
pressure like holy [ __ ] did like I would
just I would just be clammy the whole
time yeah yeah you're thinking that and
yeah it's like all the excitement leaves
the room and then you're like cuz the
moment like Mariel you'll see Mariel
gets angry at me all sex drive got ya
you are disgusting to me like you get
the [ __ ] away for me discuss sex drives
out the window yeah just like she just
like what are you doing I'm looking bad
something your dude you turn yourself
into a man again [ __ ] away from you do
you get a lot of pressure though yeah
and it's it's hard I think like I think
like the maybe the difficult part
especially for use you know that
situation where you see your wife almost
passed away just because of you know
it's like you're almost you're giving
like to take a life right yeah and
pretty much just sucks because you see
her going through this process and it's
also something it's also across that you
can't bear for her right so you just sit
on the sidelines well it's it's tough to
because I think it's we're on different
pages she's willing to do that yeah
to trade a life for life yeah oh my my
perspective is we existed before this
baby get even in the picture mm-hmm so I
don't know if I'm willing to trade off
and lose you to have a baby yeah cuz you
know this conversation pretty often
you'll ask me are you willing to risk
your life for this Tevez baby yeah and I
always say yes because in order to go
through IVF to put yourself through that
emotional and physical pain you have to
want it that badly
yeah the reserve hi for sure it's not
for everyone mm-hmm
because that's such a man that's
something I think I didn't even think
about it like that because I guess I got
would be in your situation to where I'm
like him I had to lose like I told Mary
I was like listen there's a couple of
options this world do you leave me I'm
kill myself you die I'm killing myself
because I can't start this all over five
years
are you [ __ ] crazy like I'm not gonna
find somebody else again I even
mentioned this to or to I was like hey
if I died would you would you get with
somebody else and she goes well I don't
know like that's the future I'm like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I would just stay single
for the rest of my life it's just too
hard for me it's just too hard for me to
reboot at some point it does seem like
it's just too much yeah like I'd rather
cuz I was fine being by myself before
her and she was the bonus in my life so
I can go back to being by myself
right right it's completely okay I don't
need to attach myself emotionally to
somebody else and go through the
learning process all over again like if
you die I'm done [ __ ]
like I I might date flirt around [ __ ]
around a little bit but other than that
they're not coming to my house my this
is still to me will be still this is
still our house right yeah and would
they be okay like I'm married to
somebody else and I visit your [ __ ]
grave every year I mean would they be
okay with that [ __ ] cuz that's gonna be
a little odd for me because I don't know
if I could do what I think I would be
like you it would be hard because it's
to say there's this huge risk that I
would lose you right it's like okay is
that worth it for me cuz they're all in
my mind I'm like there's other options
I'll be it it's not the same as like
having your own child but I think like
when people are set on having their own
child there's just like this
emotional attachment of feelings there's
that comes with it okay and it's
something that you're gonna have to
learn either to let go of that to be
able to to instilled like this motherly
love into this other child and if you're
okay with that then it works out but if
not that it's hard alright I think that
motherly love right now I'm giving it to
my team yeah so that's kind of like my
outlet right now where I feel like I
could be a good mother figure to my team
but we have this conversation pretty
often where you ask me like if we're
going through this again like are you
ready to go through all that physical
and emotional pain now we say yes and
then I'll ask him like can you support
me through it because this is the
difference like when he sees me go
through all this pain he doesn't mean to
do it anymore
like we he said so many times can we
just give up can we just stop trying can
we just give up on the notion of
becoming parents one day can we just
move on to adoption adoption is
something that we're definitely open to
we talked about this many times where
we're definitely open to adoption one
day but it's just I want to try to have
a little baby Anna baby Jeremy right now
and I know that if I don't give him my
all in the next few years I'm gonna get
to that age where I might be too old to
have my own biological children and I
know that if I don't do it now I might
regret it one day so that's like pushing
me through and that's me that's pushing
me forward and say I'm giving another
shot I'm gonna have the courage go
through it again and again and again
yeah but for him he sees the pain that
I'm going through and he's like please
just give up like I don't want to see
you suffer more yeah so we're always
like having this battle where I'm like
please just support me I want you to
just tell me I can do this I can do this
but he's like but I don't want to see
you in so much pain I think number one
it's something that we don't recommend
to everyone it's not something to say
hey if you're having trouble try IVF
it's great it's not great number two
it's timing right it's as a couple we
can have different timing like you're
ready to go through it I might not be
ready I'm for it you might not be ready
Hey and so that has to be aligned to and
then on top of that the risks are
different for you and then for me
oh yeah yeah like what we are putting in
the pot it's different it's chill the
way you see it is you're you're after
something and you're willing to risk
whatever it is whether it's financial
because it costs a lot number one oh
yeah it cost a lot how much does it cost
on average forty to fifty K every time
for one retrieval son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's a lot of money we love you baby
we've only spent around 150 on it holy
[ __ ] and it's a lot so that number one
is it's one one thing to consider
whether it's emotional or not that's do
you have to consider the financial stuff
- mm-hmm
and then the financial side versus
timing and you're you're committing
something different to the pot I'm
committing something different to the
pot and then that has to be aligned
because if you're not it causes friction
Yeah right like she might not feel like
she supported mm-hmm I don't feel like
I'm being heard with what's really
happening hey I might not be ready to
think like Oh am I ready to see you or
hear about you flatlining again Oh give
me injection oh that's a different thing
- I have to be a common nurse like
sticker with a needle every day multiple
times a day and then not not just that
one time I
I hit her sciatica and she's got over
like a tree like like you know timber
like she fell over she was standing
there I hit the nerve and she's wings
and like fell over on the bed and like
burst in tears all the emotions yeah
that's crazy I mean it's weird because I
think like how I see it now is psych oh
[ __ ] you you both of you actually have
big-picture thoughts but they're two
different big-picture spots
yeah I mean you're they can be your big
pictures like at the end of the day like
we are important and risking your life
is not worth it but your big picture
thing is like I'm gonna live with this
regret for the rest of my life yeah so
how did you guys find that medium like I
don't I think that's hard like I can I'm
trying to wrap my head around it
now and I don't know where that medium
is like what ha
we just constantly talk about it and and
I think for me it's I have to work up
the courage to be like ok let's do it
mm-hmm I think she's usually ready
because she'll tell me she was like okay
I think I'm emotionally ready now and
then it's kind of like at that moment
I'm like wait a second that's great
perfect I'm happy for you but I don't
think I'm ready yeah and I don't think I
comes out like that every time because
sometimes I'm just trying to ignore it
or like put it out of my mind and so it
gets to that point and I'm like oh shoot
now I have to start thinking about it am
I ready for this again I think is you're
the type that when you something's on
your mind
you need a process at first yeah you
need to come to the decision the
conclusion yourself first in your head
before you can talk about it but for me
I'm like what's on your mind what are
you thinking tell me tell me now tell me
now right and then that even adds more
pressure you know yeah I mean this is a
big thing I can't just tell you right
away if I'm ready but I think the
communication is really important where
we have to have these talks often and
say do you feel ready now do you think
we should wait another month do you
think we should wait two more months do
you think we should wait until you know
the concepts are at this stage or after
we move into your house or after the
family visit it's like whatever it is so
we have to have that communication
constantly to see to check in on each
other and see how we're doing
emotionally so what's what's I guess for
you then what is your I'm done with this
now and I'm willing to try other options
like what's what's gonna be the thing
for you I don't know that's a really
good question because I'm not the type
to give up easily like I'm very stubborn
when I want something whether it's work
with eating you know eating food that I
love like whatever it is I just need to
have it and I would keep trying until I
get there yeah I think it's good when it
comes to business where I feel like I
could give it my all and I could keep
trying and trying and trying and I won't
take no for an answer
but when it comes to infertility it's
it's really a humbling experience
because you have to think about why do
you want it so badly and what if you can
never have it ever yeah
but then my inside voice is always I
need to keep going I need to keep trying
yeah and if if I never become a parent I
think we'll definitely adopt but before
I get there I just want to give him my
all and I just want to know that I gave
him my all and there's this picture that
I look at pretty often um it's from this
woman who did IVF like 12 times and she
has this oh yeah she has his blog that
talks about all the pain that she went
through and that she ended up with a
beautiful baby girl and the baby girl
told her one day when she was like a
little older and she's like thank you
for never giving up on me yeah and that
like brings me to tears every single
time because I feel like I'm doing this
for a future child and I want them to
tell me one day like thank you for
bringing me into this world and to never
give up on me I think the interesting
thing about that is like I guess like
for adoption for me because I actually
want to adopt I actually want to dump
really bad
Muriel we actually had this the
conversation she goes I'm not sure yet
and the reason why I want to adopt it's
actually for that same very reason
because for you when you talk about
bringing a child in this world and
having that child look at you and say
thank you for bringing me to this world
for me for adoption some of these kids
didn't have that opportunity and they
actually get to say the same thing to
you worse like I wasn't asked to be
brought to this world but you gave me a
second chance
that's my adoption to me is so [ __ ]
important because my parents wanted to
adopt originally but obviously they got
a little older and obviously it's
because they kind of missed having kids
around in the house but that's the same
reason why I would want to adopt like
for me it's I mean for her I mean we
actually talked about this yesterday she
goes she asked me why I was so certain
buzz because of that reason is because I
just I just don't like the fact that
there's a kid out there that wasn't
allowed to live you know you know
they're kind of predestined to fail
right so they're kind of Bournemouth is
well without even being asked mm-hmm and
so for me like adoption is it's that
same type of beauty right so I don't
know maybe if you'll see that that same
type of connection when then and I have
a I have a friend right now who she
adopted
she has that type of connection with
their child too because you know we're
it's that second chance for people is so
important for me because like I you know
I feel like all of us had our personal
stories we got our own second chances
right but we were fortunate to have
parents around to really help and guide
us and help us be the people that we are
today and so when I see these kids who
don't have that opportunity I want to do
that for them and also to like I say
Muriel has a kid like we have our own
kid right and then she's like I don't
want to have a second kid because I
don't want to go through the whole labor
process I would adopt in a second but
then again that's probably because I had
my own kid you know so there's just a
lot to think about that and I think it's
sometimes it's hard for you because you
hear those personal stories and starts
to it makes you want you want to be the
exception to the rule
great right so I think that's why I
bring up like for you when is enough
going to be enough mm-hmm that's a great
question
she's a fighter I don't know if I can
answer that too because I don't think
there's an end inside I don't like even
for us we don't feel like we are age
right so how do you know and set a limit
when I reach a certain age that's when
I'll stop before we first started trying
me make two years and we said by the
time were 35 and they were not pregnant
yet let's adopt yeah and I just turned
35 this year and then I was thinking
about recently and I said to myself am I
ready for adoption yet and the answer
was not yet yeah I watched adoption
videos pretty often on YouTube they're
like the most emotional videos I've ever
seen I cry every single time yeah I know
that when we are ready for adoption
we're definitely open to it and my mom
actually put me on the list to adopt
from a church in Taiwan well she did
this in the beginning of the year so
it's a long waiting list but we're
definitely on that list yeah so my
family knows that were open to adoption
like they're looking around like they're
asking places in China so adopting from
China I used to be really easy when they
had the one-child policy there are many
many girls baby girls I needed to be
adopted yeah but ever since I changed
our policy and ever since they changed
their adoption policy overall it's been
really hard to adopt from China yeah so
we looked into it a couple years back we
even looked into open adoption closed
adoption there's many different forms of
it open is when the birth mother would
choose you as the parent yeah and we
actually like that more because we want
the child to know you know where they
came from to know where their family you
know if they want to rekindle with their
parents one day we're completely
supportive of it we're open to it but I
think at this stage of our life right
now we want to try a little more to have
our own biological children you know but
we would definitely be open to adoption
of one day the time it's because that
that that time restraint is it's hard
right so it's like yeah when do you say
is enough like how do you when do you
feel like for example like when people
say like how do you feel your age like I
like I just had this like I just did
that in a proposal video I hate watching
that video she makes me tear up but they
had somebody wrote to me and even this
was kind of weird I mean anything by it
but I have a lot of friends who say this
from back at home and they go oh you're
gonna get married now you're you're old
now and I'm like no you're old [ __ ] I
know you're [ __ ] old what is this
what is this your old type of thing you
know to me and that that that part's a
little weird right cuz I never feel I
still feel like I'm a child and the only
thing that keeps me grounded enough to
know that I'm getting old is when I look
at my parents that's it yeah
other that I feel like a kid yeah you
know cuz I look at my parents my oh [ __ ]
they're old oh okay yeah cuz I still
call my mom dad I come you know Mom and
Dad and in Korean and in the way I say
this even leave my child at home on Appa
and when you get older you call home
uneven happening which is like more
traditional older [ __ ] I call my
basically I call my parents mommy and
daddy I call my parents mommy and daddy
yeah as an adult
right I guess like in your case it's
like that is really something to think
about
I think turning 35 this year was really
hard for me I kind of set that time
limit dear I set the time limit and
because when you're 35 as a woman you
you're categorized and the I don't know
what they call it like the old age
it's the minute II statistically with
age and then also statistically
fertility yeah it's in a category that
it's on the decline now yeah you know
and I don't know what that study shows I
don't know how they gather that data was
it from back in the day when people were
only living till 60 done recently where
people are now living - my my best
friend is a physician he told me that it
is based on stuff from back in the day
right so when when I guess like when the
eggs are like perfect xtext technically
when you know a girl hits puberty that's
when it's like freshest funny right but
he was telling me like into your mid-30s
a little bit later it's still fine
things it's not that big of a deal
unless what he told me because he's
recent he is about to wrap up in like
the next few months but I'm guessing his
knowledge is a little bit more current
so but that's what he told me anyways
yeah so that's something to think about
isn't it nice to have a best friend
that's doctor yeah but he's a dumbass
though I'm the [ __ ] good dog these
are full of full fledge on idiot he's I
was surprised he's a doctor to be honest
with you like it's weird because even
when I talk to him I go up I haven't
sent him on the phone I was like your
[ __ ] doctor dude that's so the
education system has failed us because
he's me just a black dude just happens
to be a physician and we always say like
the funny thing about us is that we kind
of break stereotypes like he's a black
dude that became a doctor and I'm the
agent kind of like yeah [ __ ] it around
if I flip it up but damn I can be a
whole IVF process I I kind of hear about
but you don't realize how difficult it
is because I just think you just pop the
baby in make it a petri dish boom bang
boom boom baby
yeah yeah I think up to the petri dish
is manageable yeah for what we've
learned mm-hmm but then I think where
our troubles are is implantation now you
got to transfer it from a dish back into
the the uterus and then hopefully ethics
and it did stick points this sick once
for us so we know it's possible is there
a higher check as is is that like
something that's
I won't say wrong but is there something
in half inhospitable about your uterus
or is there a way to find a surrogate
mother to do that it would be a higher
chance for that for that egg to survive
we thought about that too because the
last time we did get pregnant and we had
a miscarriage
the doctor was thinking maybe it's
because my uterus is too angry mmm so it
attacks whatever it comes in whatever
that comes in that's foreign so they're
saying maybe you should just hire a
surrogate to carry your child to full
term so we looked into a last end of
last year to when he had the miscarriage
and we're open to it as well but to get
a surrogate it's like $150,000 all
because he had to carry that baby mm-hmm
you're essentially hiring them for the
year yeah oh yeah because they're just
gonna can't work right so you gotta pay
them a salary it's pay for lawyer fees
on illegal fees then they're either it's
a special insurance you have to buy them
- did your future kid either better be
in the NBA a lawyer a doctor or a really
successful comedian because at this
point did this [ __ ] cost in
hella money Oh might be for birth before
birth like just right when my kid turns
one I would just beat his ass for all
the [ __ ] pay me but that's like what
are you beating me for it's like you
don't know the [ __ ] that you put yeah
this kid is only gonna get Hemi now
[Laughter]
anything else not gonna eat shrimp daddy
dude there's me of the shells the
[ __ ] pail of this right when we find
the small shrimp in the stack like balls
on the floor oh that's your yeah you're
really expected I can rule enjoy well
guys that's that's actually a like 20 or
30 minutes more than we normally go on
this podcast a lot looking great that's
awesome
we opened up about some deep [ __ ] well
guys what can they what can they find
you guys we are pretty active on
Instagram what don't even know you had
it I'm not that active oh that's why
that's okay either it was your guys's
combined Instagram and
people thought the same thing there's
like Jeremy to one that's not Jeremy
[ __ ] good a couple [ __ ] and I saw his
thing I like damn I've ever tagged him
in anything did ya I'm not that active
yeah yeah yeah like to post a year to
post it's what I strive for so you can
find that I guess Jeremy to one SoCal
eatery you could find this at shrimp
daddy mm-hmm eat shrimp daddy is the
Instagram is it Dutch chichi dango yes
and then it's going to be sick not much
so those are all of our businesses that
we have we have a possible another one
in the books who knows what the future
holds for us but remember you guys could
catch genius brain on iTunes podcast
Spotify and basically any kind of audio
platform out there if you guys have
questions below for Jeremy and Anna say
it in the comments below on any of those
platforms specifically on YouTube ask
questions away thank you guys for
sharing the whole IVF process thanks for
having it the whole business process it
was original to be a podcast about
business it turn to something else well
that's fantastic
are you stupid sons of [ __ ] I'll see
you guys next time peace cool